apples again are you going to start him
with ronnie you guys still fighting
um have you seen his instagram
i don't really check instagram that much
well i'm
i'm concerned about ronnie's drinking
oh uh you know yeah he was getting about
drunk but he he deleted
it he was another one getting drunk
in other words he put it up and then he
took it down
i didn't want to call in about this but
you know people people send me messages
saying hey apples are you gonna
you're gonna ask this and yeah he he
didn't want to call in but he
he called in you know yeah he he didn't
want to call in about it but
to get his air time yeah he called in
about it so
ronnie if you're going to yell over
apples i can't have that i mean i want
to hear what he has to say what are you
saying
oh i'm curious what are you saying
go ahead i'm saying ronnie's
ronnie's putting stuff out there i
didn't want anything out there okay
did you delete that who put it out is
tmz
your house having a few drinks and of
course stephanie
was had a few drinks and she started
shooting this video
and if you saw in the video i took the
phone away from her
and then when she got the phone back she
started you know
shooting it again and then she put i
didn't even know she put it up
and then somebody called me and told me
about it and i told her to take it down
big piece oh is this the one i saw where
you got you're playing cards or
something with a another couple
and then stephanie gets loaded and then
she's like i thought it was kind of
funny cards you were just sitting around
bullshitting the funniest part was
she was so [ __ ] up she even even
though she posted it well
listen i gotta tell you it's great
because like stephanie
is acting kind of cute and like a little
kid who sneaks downstairs when her
parents are having company over
right and and all the adults are like
upset with her
[Laughter]
i'm confused
and ronnie's getting so [ __ ] annoyed
on this tape it's unbelievable
because you know where she was i'm
trying to ignore it
[Laughter]
where are you going hey [ __ ] what a
cute situation
he just gave up i think but this is
pumpkin i like she calls you dicko
i love that no dick hole she says dick
hole yeah i know what she says you don't
have to dick hole
all right all right all right easy easy
easy
apples you're very good at observing
ronnie is that going to be your thing
for now should ronnie prepare
for your calls that you are always going
to call in about ronnie is that going to
be your thing
stupid i i don't want to pick on ronnie
i'm a huge ronnie fan as i said before
all of this i love the show
i'm observant i like to see what's in
people's backgrounds
in a way i see your role now as ronnie's
like jane goodall you know how jane
goodall would go and watch
gorillas why is he calling in about my
instagram now
why is he what what's the point of that
because he sees it gets you
charged up and he gets some attention so
you know now it's a full-blown thing
he's watching he's the ronnie watcher
right
his thing is watching you and then
commenting and then you go [ __ ] ape
[Laughter]
[ __ ]
you